(soft happy music)
- [Voiceover] Dear BuzzFeed,
My name is Joshua
Gonzalez and I'm a senior
at University of Detroit
Jesuit High School.
All my life, I've aimed
to spread love and hope
to everyone I've encountered.
This desire to serve has
led my classmates and I
to form a new ministry we call
The Pallbearer Ministry.
This ministry's aim is to
serve homeless veterans
and other homeless people
who have little to no loved
ones present at their funeral.
As pallbearers, we ultimately become
the person's family or loved one.
My classmates and I believe that everyone
deserves to be honored
with dignity and respect
as they are brought to
their final resting place.
We act as pallbearers to honor
the brave veterans who sacrificed for us.
Whatever your calling is,
I think getting involved in your community
would ultimately change
you for the better.
We, the members of The
Pallbearer Ministry,
have acquired so much from
the sentiment of service.
I feel truly blessed
to have the opportunity
to provide dignity to the
people who truly deserve it.
What I learned from this experience
is that everyone has the
capacity and capability
to do great things and
to pursue their calling.
No matter the size of the challenge,
or the enormity of the odds,
finding ways to help others
ultimately benefits us all.
Thank you.
Thanks for listening,
Joshua Gonzalez.